I'm a naughty naughty boy we're really
gonna do this yes the time has come my
friend
alright assume the position let's go
this is sibling rivalry the most
hilarious book I'm sorry the most
successful book of the past decade most
successfully hilarious book yes I like
that it's finally a big screen motion
picture 50 we really need the intro I
think these people know what the hell it
is you know what we gotta give that the
bare minimum cuz even I didn't 100% know
was about you read it at conventions
read it as every funny cartoon character
you can imagine and it's brought so much
joy to me and the people we have read it
to uh the this novel really is a beloved
treasure to lovers of smut and lovers of
comedy and Desperate Housewives
everywhere what I love is it's mud um
and this is a story about a college grad
it's a again this is a story about a
college graduate who fills in for a
journalistic position because the
journalist couldn't find another
journalist to do it which I love it just
picks her roommate and goes in to
interview the most one of the youngest
and most she was an English major so
what if Jen graduated he goes to
interview one of the youngest and most
famous millionaires Christopher gray so
famous that nobody recognizes him
wherever he goes and a parent he stalks
her left and right yeah uh and he
apparently get babies like those Wayne
he's only in the shadows and does no no
work connecting to a millionaire uh we
saw all the work he did on posters in
the background in his office it's
signing something
REME energy something seems to like to
walk a lot and look at his song that's
it that apparently equals lots of
walking and sitting at the piano yes
what naked uh so so he comes across this
uh the this young woman on named
Anastasia Steele which is just yes that
is her reality of the real name is
Christian Grey and Anastasia Steele
Anastasia Steele is the fake name for
the romance author who writes something
like that I mean you put in a book it's
not a very credible name but the
Anastasia steals his throbbing member
it's but it's not a very uh not a very
realistic story either because he
decides he wants her even though there's
not only millions of our women the
millions other prostitutes ORS whatever
they'll do is for free and no decision
yet to submit to him as it is a pretty
much sex slave or submissive or it's
pretty much the S&M he had um and he
wants her to be the sub in what is a
vaguely BDSM as written by somebody who
probably has no clue what BDSM is and
once the quote-unquote Power Exchange
and all that stuff but doesn't want to
actually fall in love with her doesn't
want to do any of that he clearly says
that he's not of flowers and chocolates
kind of guy but he is a buying you a car
and constantly leaving you gifts kind of
guy and you can start to see what the
problem with this movie is uh it makes
no sense it makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever but while you're watching
this like you said allow you probably
know the story if you're watching this
review you don't care if it's a good
movie or not you are wondering if it's a
so bad it's good movie and it is not
here okay well here's the thing the good
news is it is a bad movie there is no
why's that no no it because it's not
like they try anything else actually
success or as no no as if they had done
that that would have been one of the
most amazing jobs anybody has ever done
to a movie ever but the if they made it
legitimately good okay but that's that's
not what people that's not what people
watching us
want to see they wants me sob wanted to
be hilariously off but the bad news is
that I don't think I've ever seen a film
that had a director actors and Scimitar
fer who have tried so hard to make a
good film out of pretty much the worst
writing you can imagine this is the room
style writing but by god it's a valiant
effort um so the only real comedy which
is still a fair amount of comedy in my
opinion is the choices that these
characters make because they are just so
inconsistent and go back and forth and
not in a way of Oh loves like that it is
clearly both these people are mentally
insane particularly him but she's pretty
bad shit crazy for constantly going back
and thinking she's in control when she's
not and yeah pretty much
it's it's still a bad film that in terms
of the smut uh it is in there in my
opinion the more erotic stuff was early
on and when it got more into like the
BDSM stuff it got less erotic and I
think part of that is because in a
strange way in the book
everything is oh my god it's incredible
the narrations gone that was 90% of
comedy right there so if you're looking
for the hilarious narration it's not
here but in the book everything that
happens the scenes I have read out loud
is holy crap holy fuck is that time she
talked she's a very eloquent writer uh
you know my inner goddess is about to
explode he's rubbing up against my sex a
holy crap uh it's an amazing thing but I
got was more funny than anything in the
movie but but again because I think
they're trying to make a good film
they're trying to add some credibility
because the character constantly says
she doesn't want to do it yet constantly
does it so I think they're trying to
make it look like at least what I got is
yeah I guess it's okay but I still have
major concerns about this and I'm doing
more because hey I kind of like him I
never got the feeling like really either
than we're like into it
like the early stuff when they're just
now each other and just doing the
regular sex I I felt much more there
than when they got into the BDSM stuff
but it's cuz I don't think they knew how
really to
shoot it from the approach of the
characters because when you take the
narration out then it's just like well I
guess will the characters make no sense
like a Rorschach test you kind of get
out of it just whatever you're thinking
in the moment like is she enjoying it is
she not one second she's getting her ass
spanked and she's like teehee this is
kind of fun and then near the end well
which one will go more to the Sun nearly
and the end is a whole other you
something similar happens and then it's
like a complete character reversal from
what she was but they constantly
flip-flopped throughout the entire thing
um but like I said uh everyone this
movie wants a second job they direct
that is one another's directing job yeah
the actors want on their acting job and
the cinematographer Devlin one
thunderous Emma Tygra job cuz they are
trying it but I think they know it's
crap and they but they can't change the
writing they were and they shit then no
see this is the problem with the film
they know it's crap but because of their
egos attached and I don't blame the this
director she was picked for this film I
don't blame her if she's like I'm not
gonna go out with this movie I mean I
wouldn't try to make this as good as I
can but because of that pride and ego
and maybe I can do this it's a
completely it's way worse than it should
have been like had you just respected
the fact that this is trash it would
have been great like this could have
been like a Vera Paul Verhoeven film and
this could've been like Basic Instinct
you know this could have been like the
room but instead it's it can't even be
that bad that it ends up being
unintentionally kind of good in an
ironic way it just you end up watching
the film and just falling asleep there
were numerous times I was just like
checking my watch that I don't really
have but pulling out my cell phone and
checking the time and being like when is
this freaking but like literally you
could listen to a thousand Housewives
and the the screening I saw just sighing
waiting impatiently for the next sexy
the same with the guys that all eight
guys I was one of
guys in the cinema we counted we counted
the Mahal every guy I'm sure my wife and
I counted them as they pass look there's
one there's one not a single guy there a
guy who was single they all came with
all ya know they're all in there I would
add a man or they were following or they
picked a random woman to follow really
close or sit next dude to pretend that
they weren't there alone that's their
beard but you could hear everybody
everybody during all of these so-called
like normal scenes where they're trying
to tell a narrative just going just God
like take it off like that's pretty much
what everybody was there
the women included like both the women
and guys you could just hear this
impatience like oh for Christ's sakes
just get naked or something because the
film is just not funny they removed all
of the really stupid bits from the book
that would make it better it made it no
no there's plenty of stupid bits but
again it's in what the characters are
doing and it's technically what they're
saying but again they got good actors
not grateful good actors thank you
mother
no cuz if you read these words that they
say to each other just in script form
it's still terrible die away it makes no
sense but by god they try their hardest
to make it sound natural and about 50%
of spending Natalie Portman and Hayden
Christensen from the Star Wars prequels
you imagine how great this movie would
have been did she wear something kind of
like that in Episode two did you have no
mother don't look at me like that it
makes me feel uncomfortable can you
imagine that if they went full Twilight
with this can you imagine
uh you know Twilight films were funnier
than Lucy I know I really I don't agree
um I still think so if you're looking
for the comedy aspect I still very much
think the choices they make are so
inconsistent and so batshit insane that
it is funny enough in my opinion see
it's funny but it's not even if you're
looking for like yeah if you're looking
for the room if you're looking for the
Star Wars prequels if you're looking for
Shambhala
pretty much um you're not gonna quite
get it except in the choices they make
um
ladies ladies he's gonna speak to you
ladies now if you read this book and
thought it was hilarious and we're just
like you know what I just want some
really fucking funny smut don't see this
movie it's not it's not you'll be bored
of kids kids all you teenagers including
the idiot teenagers who apparently
stampeded to get into this movie this
past weekend like that's a story really
like Louie they were denied entrance
because it's an r-rated okay I'm a
sadist yeah and like a bunch of teens
I'm like you've got the Internet what
are you doing even paying money for this
you can find previews of shit on the
internet for free
cool I don't get it you know it's here
here's the thing to that cuz a lot is
something I've been hearing from a lot
of reviewers I didn't get as much I'm
not gay act like it's not there but I
didn't get as much is that a lot of
people were saying this movie is very
like but anti women and stuff like that
and to some extent yes but I don't feel
that's like you see in the book it's a
definite because everything even when
she tries to resist she's like but he's
so amazing and I'm loving this so much
in this movie she seems to have much
more resistance or at least she acts
like she has more resistance to it I
didn't get a hold of that but I just
want to say that to me it doesn't seem
anti-women
as much as anti everybody nobody turns
out looking good in this now well he's
an idiot as well I don't know that's
what we're going to your looks like in
this yeah and and he he struts around
like he looks like a praying mantis with
Chris Pratt hair he's got the kind of
Chris Pratt hair going he's always got
his arms forward and this it's always
about his arms he's got like this
praying mantis thing going and there's
like white notice there's like a scene
where like he's straddling hurt he's
like a girl eyes early I'm not making
this up like so he plus he's a creeper
he's all young is you up here I don't
care I don't care how rich some guy is
if I'm a woman and this guy texts me and
is like oh so you're having another
drink and I turn around and he's right
there looking at me weird no no so
here's the fine thing again what I kind
of semi respect about the movie again in
the book if you read her saying holy
fuck well she says all the time when
she's excited about something so it must
be a good thing that he's watching her
in the movie she goes holy fuck
like what the hell is wrong with this
guy so there is a sense that they are
addressing the oddness of this but it
really doesn't matter which means which
means to me that her character in this
movie is even crazier that actually by
removing the narration you made this a
to have a brain and then forget about it
yeah because then she just looks like a
complete fucking schizophrenic I love
you I hate you I love you I hate you no
no there's a licen we'll get to the
ending with that a lot but no for me it
did seem it didn't seem like it was
trying to insult a gender as much as
trying to insult the English language
like it's not good another's who insult
an entire group of people listen it's
it's not a great book or movie for
female empowerment
I get where that arguments coming from
but it's also just a work of ridiculous
fiction like saying it's like I'm I'm
not gonna watch this because it's
demeaning towards women it's that's what
it is it's porn yeah it's it's you know
people are acting like this is news like
did you know that this is degrading to
women no shit I think honestly if the
male character is ready you like it like
in the movie it's just as degrading to
men in my opinion he makes just as
little sense but that's why this is
being read because it is just ridiculous
poor nobody reads a line like holy crap
my inner goddess was going to explode
seriously and if you do the fact that
you're taking that seriously Fifty
Shades of Grey is the least of your word
got way bigger problems and if you can
turn fantasy from reality and that
that's nuts
Fifty Shades of Grey is not gonna be the
one that breaks you okay you're already
hitting already gone your gosh so this
whole argument does like I just can't it
so degrading to what it's like it of
course it is that's what it is it's porn
you should feel ashamed reading it
that's the point of a guilty pleasure
like yelling at women like I can't
believe you're reading that what that's
the point it's a cheap thrill like who
hasn't watched yeah shit I gotta say
after watching like you know whatever
like a porno or something like that I
don't really come out of it being like
you know yeah I I feel good about men oh
really good you know very empowering to
men yeah porno was degrading to women
like what hi that's the problem and I
think this is what bothers me about the
film is the film tried to elevate itself
above smut and be like no we're gonna
we're gonna try to take this seriously
and say something and it failed like
it's just admit what it is it's porn
women are reading it because they want
say you know and if that's some woman's
fantasy that's why it's called fantasy
like it's something you can't do in real
life because it's not reality or maybe
somehow you figured out a way to do it
or belong to a certain you know club or
something that you've discovered a
millionaire who is willing to treat you
like this I still be concerned that
denote well why would you still be with
this guy so it's a batch of grace on the
one hand yes the movie is really
terrible on the other hand I think the
big deal that some people are making
about it I'm just like it I'm sorry it's
harmless you could make a bigger
argument that Twilight is more harmful
because teenagers are at least
impressionable but even then I've seen
no scientific evidence that suggests
saltines came out of Twilight like oh
this is the relationship I want like
it's freakin vampires and where will you
know I know so and I know a friend who
the ad she likes the Twilight movies and
I and she's like a grown woman I said
well why do you like these ways she's
like oh I know they're all I I just like
the beefcakes you know I like that
and I think why do you think Fifty
Shades of Grey I do that's the mentality
that you know Fifty Shades of Grey it's
sort of like have not just from people
who want to go see it but from the
people who made it all of the people
reading this at least if I'm to judge by
what I saw in the cinema the bulk of the
people interest is in reading this are
housewives of somewhere between the ages
of 35 and 50 though those were the
people and are they now if you want to
tell me that every single one of those
housewives is batshit crazy and sane and
believes that this is how the world
works and they're going to leave their
husbands the second they get out of this
to join some BDSM by you can try but I'm
sorry I give most women I give most
human beings more credit than that so
you know if if you're in the BDSM
community I I get it cuz it's not like
you're just like this is a
misrepresentation what we're all about
okay it's probably light compared to
like what they do like in the beat like
the hardest leader if these banks are
really hard well they're like that's the
big intense email but their problem is
it's supposed to be like save consensual
this and that and he like violates at
every time and she just Bennett a to
there they're both crazy so I get that
if you're in that specific community but
if you're just like on the periphery of
just like oh it's degrading to women
it's poor looking that's you know I was
able women can watch smut to I don't
care as long as they can separate
fantasy from fiction it's like I've seen
these things going around people like
I'm not gonna see it because it's
degrading one with this we know what I'm
not going to watch ghostbusters because
it condones the stalking of a woman
gross violations of the Environmental
Protection Agency
Tim looks like four villain yeah he is
kind of he is kind of right yeah uh or I
could just watch whatever the hell I
want because I realize there's a
difference between fantasy and reality
you know I was trying to think of MU
because we were talking about this a
little bit before about like how to do
kind of smut right like no it's stupid
but also make it good bound I was
thinking about it but then that that's
just very early on and then they turn to
a real real thriller what if the ones
you named are very good that the Basic
Instinct and fatal attraction stuff but
no the one I forgot about him like yeah
that that was a good way it was smut but
it was so entertaining it was so smart
was wild things like that was definite
smart well in it again that's a very
open film yeah that's that's pure smut
because he knows he was smart as he
knows he knows it's smut if you go in
knowing it's smut from the beginning see
that's the thing I don't think the
people behind this film they I think
they knew it was smut but I decided else
well we're gonna we're too good for this
we can't make smut we're gonna elevate
it and it's like you can you have to go
in knowing this is garbage to begin with
so and I think most people do and I
think that's why like when we walked out
the audience was just stunned into
silence and kind of just groaning
because I think they all thought the
same thing hey we want a garbage and you
gave us garbage like drizzled in like
truffle oil this is a oh shit what the
hell is is like I wanted my McDonald's
not McDonald's all like swear my caramel
sauce or a fancy shit out in town with
some parmesan AVG was Howard gold yeah
so if if you're going into that just
what was it I think I said that it
answers the question what would bad
Twilight fan fiction porn look like if
it was directed by Stanley Kubrick like
that should there be a lot more porn in
it if there'd be a lot more porn and we
already had that it was called Eyes Wide
Shut yes it that's what it is it's like
all you did was just you it's shot very
pretty like there's some gorgeous
shadows of you I have the cinematography
is amazing you you all know the most
erotic scene to me that was both you
beautifully shot and just sounds like
that when they put their clothes back on
uh kind of it's the scene that you were
talking about no no it's a scene where
he's at the piano a they just did it and
it's this beautiful shower ease at the
piano the city's in the background they
had these long windows it's nighttime
the city is glowing she comes out and
just lines up perfectly at the window
he's lined up perfectly the window and
she just walks up to him you know
completely naked just starts making out
with him and they walk off dog was he on
it see and I laughed my ass off because
he picks her up like she's like
straddling others are likely come woman
no no but you but there there's no line
no there's no lines there's no dialogue
it's only visual and clearly this
visually could be an interesting but
visually that was a very pretty scene at
the same time the realistic part of me
is just like they got me fucking
freezing
that's a Seattle and it's raining
outside come on like this but no I
honestly the simple in terms of like
actual like erotic stuff I mean it's
obvious they don't have any chemistry
I'll say they have a little bit more
than ever to Bella but that's not saying
much cuz like I said he's to connect I
mean that there's an outage on second
act she was fine I don't know I she
makes Selina Kyle from Batman Returns
Michelle Pfeiffer's role like that look
like Hillary Clinton yeah cuz she's like
mmm ever first scene where she just
trips like walking and I'm like great
first impression is oh no I actually
thought that they were phenomenal but
but they were good and so they tried to
get as much chemistry as they can from
such terrible material but like the
stuff that was the most erotic I like I
said it's honestly sort of the simplest
stuff like there's one scene when they
were like just dabbling with it that is
kind of funny but it's kind of clever
too there's a nice like starting to take
her shirt off and then it like stops at
her eyes and then he just stops it's
like that's the blindfold now like their
shirt on the arms in the either like
okay that's kind of clever like that's
kind of funny but it's also like just so
simple my problem is going to the room
with all the whips and stuff like that
half of them they don't use my like that
never -
ladies what a freakin teaser room you're
like what the hell are they gonna do
with half of this shit I guess that's
what coming attractions for the seat ya
know it's like the the little riding
crop thing and I try to even think like
a paddle like that it is this is some
pretty tame softcore stuff yeah
literally you could just go on a Google
like sergej my much worse like ends two
seconds they try to make it look so
intense and so
oh yeah well like we're the hardcore is
my problem with the civil ting it was
just
erotic enough like I felt like these
were all the lead ins to a much better
sex scene that never happened yeah okay
am any blindfolds it with the shirt and
now where does it go and have a yeah it
kind of like oh my gosh was starting to
like get into the you know and that was
the arc or stop it they are the only
interesting shit in the movie because
once you take out the monologue there is
nothing left it did make me realize how
little actually happens in this story
it's nothing nothing what happens
everything we found funny in the book
was her like in erm are talking about
yeah ya know and when we were giving
close to the end like it said we'll do a
spoiler corner of it but when we were
getting close to the end I was feel like
man this movies long and my wife asked
me how long is this movie and I look at
my clock and I'm like 10 not that no no
no it's about two hours but you know
what not but what is it gonna end and I
look at the clock and I'm like in three
minutes and we just give each other look
like it can't be ramping up alright like
nothing had there were there audible and
you could tell ya think I'm just like
what you could tell the groans - were
from the people who didn't read the book
anyone who read they know how ready are
how it and knew where it ended but those
that didn't when it cuts where it does
you could just everybody was just oh are
you fucking serious like I didn't know
that's I bet you cash is where the book
ends I'm like really that's where the
innocent month is obviously degrading
smut ends it's the only the funny thing
is that last shot is the only scene in
the movie we're like cuz yes we say they
can act but they're not acting acting
let's be honest here there's no
performance here that's where we go no
wait it's not
the final minute of that film is the
only point where both of them really I
thought we're stretching and I'm like oh
this is interesting real acting real
role reversal what's cut I'm like uh you
know the other thing I'll say is that
when he again just out of character
makes no sense cuz he says he can't get
personal but uh when he reveals the bits
about his past uh first of all I am far
more interested in that than anything
that happens in the movie according to
my wife you learn more she's she's read
them all she literally what what did she
say the least she called it the literary
equivalent of Tommy Wiseau's the room
yeah no I'd like she is somebody read
books already the first book is amazed
somebody recommended it to her and said
this is the funniest thing you'll ever
read in your entire life and she started
reading and she's like I'm completely
hooked like I think this is a this is a
train wreck I don't know where they're
going with this but according to her
they like explained his backstory and
that was what she said she's like it's
really the only interesting thing
attempt at being interesting yeah like
that somehow that you can't like
interested in again me that sort of ties
into the ending to like you know when
they're actually trying to really act
and they actually gives them a second
you can act or allow to act even with
scenes that still makes no sense but she
told me where it goes and I'm just like
okay so this really could have been told
in one maybe two films tops and she's
like oh yeah she's like the books are
just paddle escabi on this don't gonna
be kind of easy oh yeah so so yeah we
should should I wrap up here we go to
the spoiler corner but hey or by
Danielle gasps I really wanted some like
oh yeah maybe some mysterious Edward
Scissorhands music when she's walking
through the red dungeon you imagine this
movie done with like Tim Burton
characters like Beetlejuice pops out of
the vagina and then every Scissorhands
is trying to finger her it'd be amazing
Christian Grey shows up like I'll do
like dirt
like the Batman oh all the leather with
the nipples Batmobile music somebody
needs to make this app about YouTube
like just inner fifty Shades of Grey
intersperse like music from other elfin
scores into it look to the bad
Beetlejuice and pee-wee's big adventure
would probably be Baz for that um
probably the funniest I'll be awesome so
yeah in terms of in terms of people who
would like the movie if you're looking
for a so bad it's good no no IIIi would
star you the choices they make are very
funny because of how inconsistent they
are some of the title to ours are not
only happening to get to it don't it's
yeah you'd really have to want to be in
the mood to laugh at them it's not gonna
provide you with the Tigers you we're
out of nowhere like the room does I
don't know who this movie was for
because it's not for the Desperate
Housewives who read the book because I'm
pretty convinced they were reading it a
for the smut be because it's hilarious
mm you know and this provides just bare
minimum smut it's not really that funny
you know any kid can find better porn on
the internet guys are gonna be boy like
yeah there's some nice TNA here and
there but again she does have an
Internet
she really shocked me I see one that
he's gonna be like I'm drawn to you
which it never has explained why hey
Rhonda Royal Callie okay wait you know I
mean I'm not like cuz she clearly has no
personality no you know so you know it's
got to just be the look I'm like okay
whatever but is she she's got a nice
body not like she wakes up real nice I
feel like this is that South Park
episode with what was it called backdoor
sluts 9 and he accidentally put some
order of the Rings is like ah I hey the
production values on this are great but
I hate it when they try to tell too much
story in my porn like that's what was
real I was like great production values
too much story not enough well I think
you nailed it actually anyone looking
for the book you're gonna get the bare
minimum is what you're going to get
you're gonna get that in terms of this
there you're gonna get that in terms of
the smut you're gonna get that in terms
of the story you're gonna get none of
that in terms of the narration and just
so we don't sound like a bunch of
fucking pigs
I don't need sex to make a good movie
but if you're basically going to say hey
here's this muddiest book of the year if
you're gonna say you're poor not have
the porn I better see some smut on
screen for me there just was enough if
anything though the smut was the only
thing that would wake me up because the
rest of the attempts at storytelling I'm
like hmm and then all of a sudden they'd
start taking their clothes off I'm like
alright fine at least I got this yeah I
mean it's if any you know if you're
gotta be smut piece what I've got it's a
movie made for nobody I think the only /
the only person I think it would like
this film is the one who would I guess
if you think it's funny enough then you
would like it ironically yeah I mean
that I think sort of what bothers me
about the film way more than the book is
that the book knew it was trash and this
by trying to elevate it the only person
who could enjoy this is someone who
would try to take it serious yeah I say
or if you again and again it's looking
for the bare minimum that is really all
it is um go you know go watch better
Arad there yeah there's the water story
there's like fucking arthouse eighties
and nineties films were gritter hell
there's shit from the 70s and like this
used to be a genre of movie like the sex
yeah and this isn't gonna bring a bag I
know it's sitting at odds 300 million
it's good I guarantee you the sequels
are not going to do is go cuz people
will have learned already like you'll
get that dedicated fanbase but if you
went in to this film like everybody I
knew left disappointed hmm like you
could just hear everybody bitching about
it so I I don't see people seeing the
sequel like they saw this one I think
this ad the surprise factor of just like
who's gonna be amazed it's not yeah it's
it's actually very tame I mean I think
for housewives I don't like know that
much about this stuff for again part of
it was the funny narration just how
basically well women like the author I
say yeah I mean you're kind of so um
yeah just kind of take that for what
it's worth a lot of people have been
asking if I'm gonna do like a nostalgic
review of it
I think it's funny enough personally to
do it I think the choices they make are
so mind-boggling
just keep it close on
I make no promises so so probably when
it comes out what will make it attempt
to do it uh cuz I still think it could
be pretty fine I'm already kind of
riding it in my head so yeah I think
they're just batshit crazy enough the
choices they make that I think you can
get all I could humor out of it so but
again it's more from an analytical
standpoint like why would anybody do
this why would anyone go back and forth
but not not bad enough for me so it
could definitely be a lot worse and I
should've ever could have been a lot
worse and by not doing that it actually
legitimately is worse but I totally
understand why I I want these people to
have other jobs I don't blame you the
people involved in this have talent and
that was the biggest sin of the Spirit
getting people who every idea so uh
that's about it I'm slippery when wet
I'm just gonna scoot over here now my
inner gas is about to explode Oh